[Musique]
nous somme CC an Alabama s'est produit Bible
Belt
Nanosuit desert arena Sebastian's for
the mattel is militia Atlanta premies
poly a publican catuaba
episode is Evangelic bla over tipo
Donald Trump Adam Selzer a pizza party
so Lisa a dit la campagne Little Italy
Sawalha dollar municipal DARAB  insulte
et évangélique goyave leta algèbre
ensemble soldat Daniel McGee en jeu les
gens ont besoin d'entendre l'évangile de Jésus-
Christ et d'être des
secrets sûrs un Podesta qu'il a fait le long des
bosquets de déplacement l'opéra Jésus de la
Rebecca est un ton plus bas vers missus
votre temps
[Applaudissements]
non  ne le montre généralement jamais au total, je pense que
vous venez de vous faire chasser le diable
au nom de Jésus, il a éclaté là-bas
pour Donald Trump une condition qu'il
parle de Dieu qui d'autre pour être le
président et quelqu'un qui fait réellement
le travail de Dieu
Modèle fluidique Lizzy  à lrpc vers le bas
fidélité de la saison même sur les chansons symétrie
nouveau certains distillés tous de pecheur trop
malade être parfait mais il est bien
meilleur  Dieu, il permet aux chrétiens
d'avoir une voix président vice-président
Nom du Seigneur Jésus le recevoir en ce moment
Jésus Trump J'ai entendu une facture si elle
Del Amo des rues conservateur la cosa
Prem missive de se précipiter vers l'amour
de demain  fort
parce que ce sont les enfants de Dieu qui
sont assassinés, ces enfants sont des
bénédictions et cela me brise le cœur de
savoir que nous devons voter aussi près de la
Bible que nous nous sommes approchés de la piété
que possible et de découvrir
qui est contre  les écritures c'est
ancré dans le passé Rob Schenck chef
omnipotent la camino de val GDK
Je serai O'Connor J'espère que tu es accro au
public de la ville ouais j'ai vu Donald Trump comme un
homme non seulement comme une sorte de vide de
principes qu'il a fait '  Je ne semble pas épouser de
principes moraux ou éthiques Elam
kaliesha
Alvin mec Je suis au-dessus de Tom O'Donnell plutôt la
façon dont la perception des évangéliques maintenant
en Amérique est que nous sommes des gens qui
feront tout pour obtenir ce que nous voulons
comme je vais  Je mesure la chaleur, c'est une fuite d'énergie
de ce que notre voiture Donald Trump
commerce sur le Mississippi supprimé, aucun
pasteur Rodney Williams ne prédit que
Draghi s'il vous plaît n'était que ma solution et
ils ont pris les PC non Trump, cela ne devrait
être que oh man mrs.  dis qu'il a dit qu'il
fait ce qu'il a dit qu'il va faire tu
sais j'aime tout ce qu'il dit
tout ce qu'il fait absolument pas non
Esther Williams neva TN chaudière sa propre
police c'est aussi unique en boucle dès que vous
voyez le livre de Tobit un an avez-vous
hey démocrates  et les républicains sont deux
têtes sur le même serpent, je dis
pas à moins qu'il n'y ait une œuvre majeure majeure de
Dieu dans cette nation, l'homme que cette nation
va tomber radik une cabane dans les arbres sur son
parti Avila Republika oscillation la moi
mère
quand vous avez un président qui  est
debout avec l'église encourageant l'
église à protéger les libertés religieuses
cela aide cela rend les choses beaucoup plus faciles Je
suis d'accord avec le fait que je ne regarde pas les gens
mal pas de kuvira Rob Schenck
pacte d'aphtes Eric Trump
non à certains de mes loisirs L'équipe de Kilis
vers  la policia Je dirais que l'
évangélisme américain est en grand danger quand
on regarde l'avenir il est peut-être même sur
le point de s'effondrer Evangelic
Demopolis tah in farsi politic and
contuine habla jose de genève  récemment
ce n'était pas un million de pauvreté qu'il a expié
khalipa Leticia épuise la PA
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]